hello people I'm Gregory Elbe
I'm javi Co a and we're going to watch
how Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
should have ended yes from the channel
how it should have ended i'm javi Kawai
excuse me I'm Gabi Goodway why are you
saying mean things this was fun anyway
how it should have ended Batman V
Superman this channel is amazing if you
guys haven't subscribed to them already
you should do it I'm really interested
in seeing this because uh oh you were
saying how it should have ended the
channel the movie them no but the
channel is good then they should
subscribe to the channel house yeah okay
you were I thought you were making a
weird joke earlier that was being
vicious those families move on okay yes
it's the world my mom sneezes well this
changes everything
like me some coffee well that was a
really sudden change in attitude yeah
I'm sure I actually don't have a lot of
friends sweet okay get everyone else
building now
I was going to stay here
so me insurance
you better technically you hit me
also I just saw you murder a bunch of
people so I'm gonna have to take you in
Oh Groupon Doral fruit is there I've got
you master wide
ah super cold he said that to me all the
time
never never like
ha roof you have to listen to me Lex
Luthor is behind everything yes yes
exactly why not that because I'm faster
than a speeding bullet
you
you are going to kill Superman he was
gonna try
oh I bet you different I just seem to
remember you lying on the ground crying
out for your mother what was her name
again
you worked Martha I'm sorry our moms
have the same name he's really sensitive
about it
what are you gonna do your mom isn't the
only Martha in the world dude all day
like this is certainly not what I
thought in hanging out with you two is
going to be like it's gonna be a while
for this job
because your fan oh let me pick up the
check you mean say Martha food if you
say okay it's just too easy now I wish
to to just kill you
that was really really well done yeah
the bills cannot be unrung he is
boundless I'm impressed
of course you're impressed I've never
seen one of his videos before and I
wasn't expecting to be so Watson team of
people and they're they're fantastic at
what they do and you know I think what
the great at doing obviously is taking
things that audiences are really saying
or thinking or thinking you know putting
it into like some type of like I don't
know the word for not Family Guy but you
know like this kind of a Comedy Central
vibe to it well yeah I mean well in
improv as you already know when you're
in the situation you see something weird
you're supposed to call out the obvious
thing and that's what they're doing is
they're taking these scenes and they're
just calling out the most obvious thing
that everyone else would be pointing out
if they were in that situation yeah
exactly I love the part where when Ben F
when I Bruce Wayne's calling his calling
Jack he's something didn't I was
wondering like know it what are they all
doing why are we still at work yeah okay
we can go now the whole jelly bean thing
I how do you feel about that in the
movie the jelly bean moment or the Jolly
Rancher moment the Jolly Rancher moment
was probably most powerful moment in the
whole movie they being serious for now
it really showed the evil seductive side
of Lex Luthor where I can't tell you
answer cuz it was like he's going to do
this with a man you know it wasn't like
it's kind of like when Javier Bardem was
you know touching James Bond's legs and
Skyfall mmm
you know that was an uncomfortable
moment yeah just like that moment Zack
Snyder knew exactly what he was doing
you know what I hate about that flash
sequence Bruce Wayne starts off like
he's having this
right yeah and then he wakes up from
that dream to find the flash yelling
things about Louis and stuff at him you
know and then he wakes up from that like
an inception style thing right but
here's the problem those things are all
supposed to really happen in the future
so does that make Bruce Wayne like
capable of predicting the future
suddenly he's not predicting the future
flush spoke to him and then showed him
like the other first stream to know
that's what you got from it it doesn't
say it flash me didn't think he was
dreaming it doesn't make a [ __ ] bit of
sense but that's what happened this
flash was giving him visions no no
you're wrong what am i wrong look at the
order of events he's having the dream
about dark seed or someone that he wakes
up from that dream and to find the flash
talking him then he wakes up from that
in the same spot so he was dreaming
about the flash okay so the flash didn't
give him those visions unless the flash
entered his dreams in no instance in the
comic books am i aware of them and being
clairvoyant
ever so I'm pretty sure the flash was
giving him those dreams I just don't
think the writers thought that through
how the double dream sequence will not
make any sense mm-hmm this also goes
back to the inherent issues with
Superman at large is just too amazing
that none of the things that happen in
the movie really make sense
I found this Superman to be a million
times more charming than the Superman
that we have gotten from Man of Steel
and a man yeah I could I can't agree I
can't argue there I'm still kind of
stuck on the bullets the the Kryptonite
bullets yeah Batman no is how powerful
Superman is why was he shooting at him
with anything other than kryptonite ever
actually didn't ever think of that I
don't know why I can't tell if you're
joking with me no I'm being serious oh
okay I can never tell and I don't know I
don't know why this is the first time
I'm hearing this I feel like well yeah
it's so obvious a lot of people should
have told me before I'm joking
no way because I can't tell with you I
can't tell feel like you're really good
at [ __ ] with me well you're being
serious
totally serious okay but I never heard
that before
Wow this movie just gets stupid it's
pretty man it's pretty that was pretty
gentle I when I first reviewed it even
though people thought me nitpicky um the
more I looked it's just not a good film
it is not a good it's like sure Batman
is cool this is not a good film with
Batman going in and charging and would
have made Batman so much more uh
interesting as a superhero because in
the film he was just on the sidelines
yeah the whole time like yeah do you
think guys Superman and Wonder Woman
fight them fight fight the Doomsday well
he did lure them over to the city and
the stupid thing with the sphere so amy
adams drops it in the thing yeah and
then goes to get it back out it's like
why did you even why did you even do
that
and then what's his name shows up in the
cartoon um with the things like I'm not
part of this it sucks but it picks up
and the whole thing about Superman dying
yeah who's gonna buy that never
Antarctica's on it like what a what a
bold ending to go with Superman dying
and I'm like I never bought it for a
single moment that he was gonna stay
dead in the in this yeah Batman V
Superman okay well I mean it he doesn't
stay in the comics it comes back yeah I
know but still like the way it ended
people thought it was litter people like
making articles about how it's like a
bulb ending to go with when it's really
not the issue isn't him dying the issue
is how they handled him dying it's just
what the execution was awful that's all
I mean it was already a lot of as a
noise fest of [ __ ] and rocks and
this and that and then he goes and does
that it's like really do birthday come
on seriously my biggest issue with that
film that my number one issue there was
literally zero reason for them to fight
there was no reason for them to fight at
all hey there was a 1% chance Superman
could have been the enemy that's nuts
that's enough that's in really Wow
Batman must be cheeseburger when
Superman shows up in Batman's arena
mm-hmm Superman all he had to do was
just keep his distance and explain
what's going on like hey my mom's been
kidnapped Lex has been setting
this up we just got to work together my
mom's name's Martha
holy [ __ ] that's my mom's name yeah
let's work together yeah that's all it
could have been and then it said it's
like Superman
I don't know God is like feelings or
something it was like to [ __ ] this guy
I'm just gonna fight him what didn't he
have to fight him to get his mom back he
had to kill the Batman and bring the
Batman oh man but his whole thing was
his whole thing was we got to work
together yeah and he could you're right
like you're right like he could have
just been floating around Batman like
this going hey no no don't yeah you
can't touch me because I'm awesome so
here's what's up that's Cynthia but then
there wouldn't have been visual effects
it was so simple you hear Batman vs
Superman that's all I wanted to see her
do I look like hey guys hate to say it
but Civil War does prove that you could
have done this right if they had just
focus on that like you said just focused
on that yeah Batman versus Superman and
not got caught up in Wonder Woman and
the Justice League if they just focused
on that and it was a half hour shorter
or even 45 minutes shorter I think the
movie would have been much much better
for this video I am wearing a Deadpool
shirt and he's wearing a spider-man
shirt because we know how you DC fans
would be the hardcore one that's always
support these they're gonna be so mad at
us right now I could sit here and say I
really like DC I think DC Batman's my
favorite comic over here of all time and
I wings my second favorite you know I do
like the Marvel movies more than the DC
movies and now marina Deadpool shirt
spider-man was in Civil War those movies
know how to do it right end of story
yeah um sorry I kind of checked out
halfway through what you're saying
listen you should subscribe to how it
should have ended immediately do it now
it'll be worth everyone's time
everyone's time best channel out that
one of them listen guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe today and
become a reject yeah we'll be it'll be
cool we can boogie chebika way has a
channel the Jabby co a channel where he
primarily does you know reviews
reactions based off indian money yes
indian video i merrily it's not
primarily primarily a lot it's quite a
lot there's a heavy
of indian content but i still do a lot
of American stuff cuz Bali was where
it's at people you know they're bigger
than Hollywood it's more than Bollywood
but yes it's more than Bali well India
has got different film industries it's
complicated
yeah like relationships you could follow
me on Instagram and Twitter you can
follow Jia be there to Instagram and
Twitter yes and I have a Facebook page
to Rio rejects I would Facebook page
follow javi yeah and to all the woman
out there who watch this channel I'm
single who beat you to the punch
I thought you were gonna think okay he
was gonna said I was gonna say stick to
for them to stop contacting me so much
Oh cuz I'm getting bombarded these days
with constant female fans all the time
messaging me yeah leave him alone and
come over to Jeffy's channel oh welcome
you
am I not supposed to hear what you just
said because I wrote of everything you
just said don't be so coy